[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes qué gusto estar con
ustedes soy una persona a la que le
gusta llamarle las cosas por lo que son
utilizar el nombre de las cosas para
referirme a ellas muchas veces esto me
ha puesto en situaciones incómodas
porque suelo ser muy directo y algunas
personas como que no les parece mi mejor
amiga hace poco tiempo me presentó un
libro que es de este cuate que parece
que estaba salido de una película muy
extravagante y muy flamboyán él se llama
clutter rafael y perdón si pronunciaba
el nombre pero mi francés está bien
oxidado su libro lo que pretendía hacer
era ponerle nombre a las culturas
definir a un país después de haber hecho
estudios antropológicos estudios
sociales estudios culturales poner la
esencia de un país en una sola palabra
él utilizaba verbos para todas estas
culturas y al ser humano por excelencia
le gusta sentirse especial le gusta
sentirse diferente entonces así como ha
visto quizá algunos de ustedes les podrá
ofender lo que diga el día de hoy cuando
se enteren de qué palabras utilizó para
para definir a méjico y yo no soy así o
sea quizá las las personas que conozco
algunos pueden serlo
pero yo no pero definitivamente creo que
existen patrones de comportamiento y
patrones culturales que si podrían
definir en una generalidad a los
mexicanos pero primero vamos a irnos con
algunos otros países que a mí me
gustaron mucho las palabras que se
utilizaron por ejemplo el ser el ser se
utilizó para definir a los ingleses eres
lo que eres literalmente por ejemplo y
pensar eres lo que piensas con los
franceses con los italianos eres lo que
haces
actúas y veo equipos de la manita porque
ya todo se convierte en italiano na más
con hacerle así y con los alemanes por
ejemplo se puso obedecer y cuando busqué
alemana en google salió este cuate y
pues definitivamente esto no te lo pones
a menos que obedezcas alguien que te
digo que te lo pusieras
y lamentablemente la palabra que se
utilizó para definir a méxico el verbo
de nuestra cultura fue aguantar es decir
tolerar tener algo que te duele y aún
así no hacer nada para cambiar lo que a
mí se me hizo extraño no y me puse a
leer un poco sobre la historia y me di
cuenta que sí que si hemos aguantado y
hemos aguantado un chorro hemos
aguantado a distintos tipos de personas
y lamentablemente hacemos cosas que
alimentan que este tipo de aguante siga
sucediendo y ustedes se preguntarán
madres el país lleva siendo así un
chorro de tiempo está haciendo así
actualmente seguirá siendo así realmente
puedo hacer algo para cambiarlo si
cambio yo cambiará lo demás y justamente
es lo que quiero platicar con ustedes
porque también cuando hemos visto casos
de aguante hemos visto dolores que
sufrió el país y que nos han llevado a
hacer cosas impresionantes ustedes lo
vivieron muy de cerca si es que todos
los de aquí son de puebla el 19 de
septiembre del 2017 el país se sacudió
de una manera tan fuerte que casi 4.000
familias terminaron sin hogar que hubo
más de 400 muertos o al menos esa es la
cantidad que se dio a conocer porque
seguramente fueron muchos más
se vieron imágenes como esta que nos
llenan de tristeza yo en ese entonces
estaba fuera del país y la piel se me
puso chinita cuando en las noticias
empecé a ver lo que había sucedido
afortunadamente el día que méxico se
cayó
los mexicanos se encargaron de
levantarlo porque también vimos como
todo un país se movilizó haciendo
cadenas humanas para sacar escombros y
sacar cuerpos de entre ellos si no
estabas en las ciudades donde había
temblado comoquiera hacías cadenas
humanas para sacar víveres que la gente
recolecta va de buena fe para que la
gente tuviera que vestirse que comer que
beber y no te tienes que ir tan lejos
con estas acciones la gente en la ciudad
de mexico estoy seguro que en puebla
también sucedió solo le quitaban la
clave a su wifi para que la gente en las
calles tuviera una manera de comunicarse
con las personas que no encontraban
y la pregunta que yo me hago después de
haber visto esto después de haber visto
las dos caras de un país que aguanta y
un país que actúa
y me la preguntó constantemente y aún no
encuentro la respuesta quizá ustedes la
tengan pero les dejo que se la lleven a
su casa tenemos que esperarnos a que
pase algo de esta magnitud para darnos
cuenta que si le exigimos al gobierno si
nos hace caso y que si dejamos de ser
indiferentes las cosas se pueden cambiar
para darnos cuenta que en la unión está
la fuerza y que si actuamos y dejamos de
quedarnos sentados nada más criticando
lo que sucede algo positivo y algo que
transforme al país puede ser logrado y
depende de todos nosotros imágenes de
cómo había tumultos de gente cantando el
cielito lindo porque habían sacado el
último cuerpo que se había registrado en
ese lugar de una bandera y sant 12 y
gente cantando el himno nacional
celebrando que muchas manos lograron
cambiar las vidas de algunos que habían
quedado atrapados y de todo esto de toda
esta observación y análisis me puedo
llevar una palabra y quiero compartir se
las porque es una palabra que para mí es
de suma importancia y que si todos la
pusiéramos en práctica todos los días
una historia diferente estuviéramos
viviendo la palabra es movimiento para
mí el movimiento es importante por
muchísimas razones la primera razón es
porque cuando te mueves empiezas a hacer
cosas y decir y hacer son cosas
completamente distintas
la palabra convence pero el ejemplo
arrastra y les pregunto padres de
familia yo lo he visto no soy papá pero
un hermanito de cinco años y el niño
aprende viendo entonces tú enseñas
haciendo y aprendes viendo como un niño
que aprende a rasurarse con su papá
enseñándole al lado cómo se hace la
segunda razón es porque cuando te mueves
con el suficiente esfuerzo empiezas a
sudar empiezas tres fuertes empiezas a
sudar y la suerte es dividendo del sudor
mientras más sudo más suerte tengo
fíjense qué curioso mucha gente se
pregunta de dónde están en la suerte
porque este cuate que aparentemente hace
lo mismo que yo tiene tanta suerte en lo
que está haciendo porque esa persona
decidió moverse en los lugares correctos
que lo hizo prepararse para tomar las
oportunidades correctas entonces ahí te
das cuenta que la suerte la vas
construyendo tú mismo en el camino la
tercera razón la tercera razón es porque
cuando te mueves empiezas a conocer lo
que hay allá afuera en finanzas hay dos
palabras que me gustan mucho que es la
incertidumbre y el riesgo la
incertidumbre es lo que sabes que no
sabes y él
es lo que no sabes que no sabes por qué
ni siquiera está a tu alcance de la
vista ni siquiera está en tu horizonte
visual para darte cuenta que está ahí
afuera y no sabes a qué te vas a
enfrentar entonces cuando tú te propones
arrancar algún proyecto alguna meta y
seguir algún camino desde afuera puede
que te estén vendiendo esto y de repente
te das cuenta dice es hachís no está tan
fácil como parecía mejor no me meto a
eso o me atrevo a hacerlo a pesar de las
dificultades que éste va a presentar si
entra razón por la cual moverse para mí
es importantísimo porque cuando te
mueves te vas conociendo dicen que una
de las cosas más difíciles en esta vida
es el autoconocimiento conocerte del
todo conocer que te gusta conocer para
qué eres bueno y cuando te mueves
empiezas a hacerte las preguntas
correctas y eventualmente vas a tener
las respuestas a esas preguntas te vas a
preguntar a pesar de lo fugaz que es
esta vida a pesar de que todos los días
te tengas que concentrar en ser el mejor
hijo de ser el mejor amigo de ser el
mejor estudiante de ser el mejor papá o
mamá te vas a preguntar si lo que estás
haciendo en ese momento de tu vida te
convence de si te gusta
y si te estás acercando al met u quieres
estar martin seligman es un psicólogo
que define a la felicidad con tres
niveles el primer nivel de felicidad es
la felicidad de donis está cuando tú te
comes una hamburguesa cuando comes unos
tacos y con él lo disfrutas estás feliz
en ese momento pero un año después no te
despiertas y this way'
hace un año me comienzos tacos eso no
pasa
la felicidad hedonista fácil viene y
fácil se va el segundo nivel de
felicidad es la felicidad involucrada
cuando tú encuentras un espectro de
tiempo que tiene un inicio y tiene un
final y te involucras esforzándote
dedicándole tiempo invirtiendo tiempo
pero cuando acaba el proyecto cuando
acaba la essa esa inversión
las las gracias y continúas con tu
camino que nos lleva al tercer nivel de
felicidad este nivel de felicidad es
difícil de alcanzar pero de todo corazón
les deseo a todos ustedes que ya lo
hayan encontrado o que lo encuentren en
algún momento de sus vidas este nivel de
felicidad es el tener una vida con
propósito quiere decir que cualquier
minuto que estés dedicándole a esa meta
a ese sueño no es un minuto mal
invertido no es un minuto que te cueste
trabajo al contrario es un minuto que
disfrutas y que sabes que lo estás
haciendo con una razón con ese propósito
de vida cuando te conoces de esa manera
entonces posiblemente corrijo
seguramente vas a hacer las cosas de una
mejor manera y última razón por la cual
creo que que moverse es importantísimo
porque encuentras personas con esos
mismos valores porque encuentras
personas con las cuales sumar voluntades
porque el conocimiento como el éxito no
se regalan se comparten y se multiplican
y cuando suman los esfuerzos correctos
tu proyecto tu pensamiento tu idea llega
a un siguiente nivel
este mundo se trata de estar
compartiendo se trata de estar sumando
se trata de colaborar se trata de llevar
las cosas a un nivel en el que
conjuntamente tengan un impacto
impresionante para mí el proyecto en el
que decidí moverme lo hice con con mi
mejor amigo que se llama pablo marín uno
de mis mejores amigos no se pueden
ofender en los que los que no son los
lugares de amigos y se llama plural yo
plural yo nació el año pasado en la
época electoral en la que todos hablaban
de las elecciones en las que a todos les
importaba lo que estaba pasando en este
ámbito y el primero de julio decidimos
sacar una aplicación para que todos
desde su celular pudieran participar
decidimos hacerlo en el ámbito de
delitos electorales porque estudiando un
poco los casos nos dimos cuenta que en
el 2012 sólo 1 956 reportes de delitos
electorales y en un país de 125 millones
de personas donde elección tras elección
cada vez se pone más turbia más opaca y
con menos transparencia pues parece un
poco ilógico que sólo 1 956 delitos
electorales estudiando un poco más que
había detrás de todo esto nos dimos
cuenta que para presente
delito electoral tú como ciudadano
tenías que formarte cinco horas en una
fila ir al ministerio público ir a la
fepade presentar tu queja
hacer papeleo que te trataban con una
mala cara perder la rutina perder medio
día y que al final del día no pasará
absolutamente nada que el delito que
denuncias te siguiera impune y que no
cambiará nada porque lamentablemente
méxico es el país en el que puedes
violar derechos humanos puede ser
corrupto puedes robar porque no te va a
pasar nada a menos que nosotros nos
pongamos a cambiarlo nosotros con este
ejercicio con este experimento de sacar
la aplicación un solo día sin publicidad
pagada con un esfuerzo de dos morritos
de 25 y 28 años que se decidieron hacer
las cosas con lo que tenían donde
estaban y logramos la cantidad la
cantidad de reportes de 30 mil
acercamientos una aplicación que lo
único que hacía era permitirte
participar desde tu celular
que pudiste haber hecho toda tu vida
como ciudadano facilito tanto el proceso
que nos dimos cuenta que uno la gente si
quería actuar a la apatía que tanto nos
pintan y que intentan generalizar como
como si fuera de nuestra generación de
que somos apáticos indiferentes es un
espejismo
si queremos participar pero todos
necesitamos las herramientas correctas
para hacerlo y nosotros después de sacar
este experimento nos dimos cuenta que el
moverse había funcionado pero que el
moverse tenía ciertas reglas ciertas
reglas que tenías que seguir para que
ese movimiento tuviera fuerza para poder
transformar los espacios la primera es
que siempre tienes que moverte hacia
adelante porque el movimiento muchas
veces se confunde con progreso o sea la
gente piensa que está progresando pero
puede que sea una silla mecedora que va
hacia adelante y va hacia atrás y por
estar haciendo muchas cosas tu mente se
nubla y dices voy muy bien pero en
realidad no estás progresando con lo que
estás haciendo entonces es importante
ver en dónde estás parado y ver cómo vas
avanzando número dos cuando te empiezas
a mover la segunda regla es empezar a
hacerlo todo
todos los días aristóteles decía que la
excelencia es una repetición de actos la
excelencia no es un acto es un hábito
estar haciendo todos los días y la
belleza de estar haciendo todos los días
está en la repetición misma porque si un
día te salen mal las cosas no pasa nada
al día siguiente lo vas a volver a hacer
entonces te alcanza para corregir lo que
estabas haciendo hasta ese momento
tercer regla que nosotros encontramos
detrás de ese movimiento uno siempre es
más que cero nuestra aplicación no era
perfecta lo que estábamos haciendo no
estaba diseñado a la perfección no tenía
la mejor experiencia de usuario no tenía
el mejor diseño pero uno siempre fue
mejor que cero hacerlo contundentemente
sirvió para crear un impacto no importa
qué tan corto sea el camino si pisas con
fuerza dejas huella y este fue el
el ejercicio que nosotros hicimos y a mí
me gusta englobar esta experiencia en
una palabra y esta palabra me hubiera
encantado inventar la pero la a mí me la
compartió mi mejor amiga y gai sido
puede ser la clave para crear lo que se
te antoje en esta vida guy sido es una
regla de oro para mí en todo lo que hago
en la vida ya ha sido es washington
porque ahí entra la regla más importante
de empezar a moverte empezar a moverte
hoy
get your sit down no más procrastinación
no más excusas no más pretextos parate
de donde estás sentado y ve a buscar lo
que te mereces en la vida después no hay
después después las cosas se enfrían
después tu interés cambia después las
personas cambian después las personas
envejecen y después
pues ya se te pasaron las oportunidades
y tú mismo te estás flagelando de no
haberlas tomado cuando aún podía
si aplicáramos todo eso a nuestra vida
quizá el verbo que nos define como
mexicanos dejaría de ser aguantar porque
no el mexicano que propone por qué no el
mexicano que mejora las cosas porque no
el mexicano que crea nuevas
oportunidades que crea un nuevo
ecosistema para que se den las cosas
como nosotros quisiéramos porque no el
mexicano que transforma porque no el
mexicano que demuestra que si podemos
elegir que si podemos hacer bien las
cosas que nuestro metro cuadrado- así
como este círculo en el que estoy parado
es suficiente para hacer lo que me toca
y un poquito más
independientemente de hablar
en este conjunto de verbos definiendo un
país llevémoslo algo más simple quizá
hay un verbo que te define a ti como
persona y si no estás contento si no
estás conforme con eso que te define bay
cámbialo y si se te hace imposible pues
las cosas imposibles en realidad no
existen todo es imposible hasta que se
hace sólo diría nelson mandela para
terminar y sin alma sin nada más que
agregar seré breve mereces más muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]